why am I doing this I don't know if it's
a very good question I asked myself that
question as I go to sleep every night
Jimmy has this unique ability to be
really funny with an edge but not being
mean-spirited his observations are
razor-sharp we were looking for someone
with universal appeal Mike talks a lot
about Bob Hope and Carson and some of
his early heroes who hosted the awards
and so we were kind of looking for
someone of that model Mike and I talk a
lot were old friends we've watched a lot
of Oscar telecast together we dreamt of
producing the Oscars for an
embarrassingly long time we want to try
to give people the feeling we had as the
other people watching the show our
themes to inspire and celebrate the
movie thank you so much for putting me
in this position this is been the joy of
my life I love really emotional
acceptance feature when we get this
moment to shine and you talk about that
teacher or that parent or your wife or
your husband or kids and I start to
choke up when I first started acting it
was because of my desire to connect
everyone should I sing inside each of us
that life that I believe exists in all
of us to go out there
those moments the unscripted moments and
the spontaneous moments the memorable
moments we take with you those are the
things that really stay with me
one thing that I remember that I thought
was just great Roberto Benigni early
walk across the piece it was it was
almost punk rock or some combination of
Fred Astaire and a crowd surfing and I
thought that was just amazing thank you
thank you this is a moment of joy and I
want to keep everybody because you are
the rage of the joy
what's unique for Mike and I obviously
because we are both film producers we
know how hard all these people work to
get here we know how many movies they
worked on and how hard they've honed
their craft and so we know what a big
night it is for everyone we just want to
make it the most special night for them
that we can never thought I'd be here MA
alright thank you thank you thank you
yes yeah thank you mom and dad whoever
we forgot we love you love you thank you
thank you so much
the Academy Awards are sacred ground and
I revere it and I know Jen feels the
same way it was just really conscious of
the responsibility it's a very high bar
and we want to measure up and just give
people a night where they can just enjoy
why they love the movie oh yeah you read
in over the years some of the great
hosts to be included in this group Billy
Crystal Ellen DeGeneres and Chris Rock
is humbling it really is and it's
something that very few comics gets the
opportunity to do and for me that's very
exciting
[Music]
[Applause]